quando eu era adolescente eu vim aqui na
usp aqui na cidade universitária onde
houve que a usp era a melhor
universidade do país
eu entendi muito bem porquê mas ok
aí me disseram que eu teria que estudar
muito para passar aqui na usp era muito
difícil eu estudei muito e não passei na
usp eu passei na unesp
a unesp é assim como a usp é uma
universidade estadual paulista e tem
campi espalhados por todo o estado de
são paulo
o campus para qual foi aprovada fica em
bauru é uma cidade há mais ou menos
quatro horas e meia aqui da capital são
paulo onde morava mas eu não sabia disso
na época
o campus fica numa rua de terra sem
número
bem longe do centro da cidade e quando
eu cheguei lá eu vi que era muito calor
em bauru também não sabia disso
lembro uma vez liguei pro meu pai está
aqui do orelhão orelhão revelando a
idade e do orelhão no fim de semana
naquela época e telefone fixo era muito
caro
e aí estava embaixo do leão e eu
transpirar
bom eu não sabia se a unesp é uma boa
universidade eu não sabia se o curso meu
curso é um bom curso não sabia de nada
não tinha nenhuma forma de avaliação
naquela época nenhum termo de comparação
nenhuma referência
eu fui aprovada para o curso de
comunicação social habilitação em
jornalismo
eu escolhi esse curso olha só na fila de
inscrição do vestibular que na época
revelando a idade de novo era feita
pessoalmente
aí eu tava lá na inscrição na
desesperada para chegar a minha vez
ficha de inscrição em branco
olhando o nome dos cursos e pensando por
que eu queria fazer uma coisa que tem um
social aí meu pai novamente estava lá
comigo falou assim você escreve bem
turismo preenche me inscrevi passei foi
assim que eu escolhi o meu curso um
susto
bom eu não sabia que o estudo da
disciplina de jornalismo
quando fiz a matrícula ouvi-la
sociologia filosofia foi nossa
eu não sabia o que faz um jornalista
exatamente o que faz um jornalista com
que a rotina de uma lista onde trabalham
jornalistas quais são as possibilidades
de ganhar dinheiro eu não tinha a menor
idéia mas eu achava legal você
jornalista legal ainda aqui eu nunca
tivesse falado com o jornalista a minha
vida
quando começou o curso eu fui vendo que
esse problema não era só meu
só eu que estava perdida sem saber o que
eu estudar aqui que eu ia fazer depois
formada como era honesta como era o
curso onde ficava bauru será calor ou
frio
os meus colegas de curso também estavam
perdidos
meus colegas da unesp estão perdidos os
meus colegas do ensino superior e da
minha geração e das gerações anteriores
o problema é a maneira como a gente
escolhe o ensino superior no brasil a
gente tem que escolher uma carreira
específica antes de entrar na
universidade
e olha só isso me angustiou tanto dessa
forma que a gente entra no ensino
superior que eu resolvi fazer disso meu
objeto de vida eu estourei meu doutorado
muitos anos depois com o professor
renato pedrosa que é matemático como se
diz que uma universidade melhor que
outro baseado no que você diz uma
personagem é melhor que outra e daí você
poderia fazer essa escolha foi estudar
na unicamp
outra universidade estadual paulista eu
também ajudei a desenvolver no meu
trabalho que foi mencionado aqui
são o ranking universitário folha aqui
venha a ser uma forma de ajudar a quem
precisa
escolhemos essa carreira específica no
ensino superior o ranking universitário
foi à bahia curso de graduação e
universidades todos todo o país as duas
mil e trezentas instituições de ensino
superior do país estão avaliadas
eu coordeno essa iniciativa há seis anos
desde que a gente publicou a primeira
edição
o problema é que a gente tem que
escolher nessa carreira específica e o
sistema rígido é você escolhe a carreira
e você não pode mudar
aí eu lembro do meu afilhado o joaquim
joaquim joaquim daqui um tempo né
pessoal é fazer aquela pergunta clássica
joaquim o que você quer ser quando
crescer
o joaquim talvez fale além de que ele
quer ser jogador de futebol
talvez ele fale uma profissão uma área
mas ele não vai falar que ele quer fazer
economia empresarial e controladoria com
ênfase em negócios internacionais é o
nome de um curso gente e detalhes em
negócios internacionais você concluir
antes de entrar na universidade
quem fala não só vou trabalhar aqui com
negócios internacionais nacionais não me
interessam
joaquim também não vai falar que ele
quer ser físico com habilitação em
óptica e fotônica isso também é um curso
só super específico
o problema é que a gente tem que
escolher essa carreira antes de entrar
na universidade
o sistema rígido você abre a porta
entrei lá em economia empresarial não
consigo decorar seu nome tem que ler é e
controladoria com ênfase em negócios
internacionais é abrir entre
universidade e plantando fazendo as
disciplinas
aí começa a amadurecer comércio conhecer
outras pessoas outras áreas começam
fazer ter noção do que é o curso que
estou fazendo
às vezes passa um estágio eu fui
hum se fosse por aqui se mudasse um
pouquinho de área
hum você não pode mudar de idéia se você
mudar de ideias é um perdido na vida que
não sabe o que quer e não pode se você
mudar de idéia
você volta a 0 e tem que abrir a porta
de novo o conhecimento que você adquiriu
no caminho ótimo legal fica pra você mas
para o sistema de ensino superior
você já era eu tenho um amigo e de
autorização dele para mencionar tem um
amigo que ele entrou em física nem era
habilitação óptico fotográfico mesmo
depois de dois anos ele entrou em rãs
lanuf largou vestibular
depois de dois anos entrou em relações
internacionais e depois de dois anos ele
entrou em letras e hoje trabalha como
jornalista
imagina a cada dois anos
você tem que sair do sistema e decorar
se a samambaia angiospermas gimnospermas
porque isso vai cair no vestibular
eu não lembro eu tenho uma outra amiga
ela fez jornalismo se formou
aí ela ficou dez anos tentando se
encaixar uma carreira lá que promete ela
conhecia quando ela toma decisão talvez
na fila da inscrição do celular e depois
de dez anos ela fez medicina veterinária
e hoje ela faz medicina veterinária o
que ela acumulou no caminho ótimo fica
pra ela mas para o sistema era zero
o problema é que a gente toma essa
decisão do ensino superior muito cedo
se vocês assim como eu e assim como mais
da metade de quem está no ensino
superior do país fez ou faz universidade
na idade universitária que é o período
de 18 a 24 anos
você escolheu a sua carreira específica
que você não pode errar
na adolescência eu escolhi com 17 anos
o problema é que o céu meu lado o
cientista falando problema de um cérebro
de um adolescente
ele não está pronto a parte que toma de
se ser preparada é que é capaz de tomar
decisões de longo prazo é a última parte
a amadurecer no cérebro estudos recentes
têm mostrado que ela amadurece
aos 24 anos que é quando termina a idade
universitária que significa isso que
decisões de longo prazo como escolher
uma carreira específica pra vida inteira
tomadas na adolescência
elas têm grandes chances de serem
impulsivas e impulsivas e a gente sabe
disso
e a gente sabe que o adolescente não tem
condição fisiológica para tomar uma
decisão ea gente sabe quantos
adolescente não tem como a condição
física e psicológica tomar a decisão
o ensino médio ele não vou nem comentar
um preparo ele nem de longe a gente fala
adolescente
você tem que escolher sua específica e
se você rabo são perdido na vida que
acontece
quem erra é quem escolheu a carreira
específica e erra e sai se ferrar
quem escolheu a carreira específica
errado e fica-se ferro
quem escolheu certo acertei escolher a
carreira que é a minha carreira também
se ferro explicou explicar porque quem é
e sai bom lá né entrei na carreira
quando soube que era exatamente aí
putz não era isso não era isso que eu
queria estudar
comecei a fazer estágio assunto saco vou
sair
bom essa pessoa primeiro perdeu tempo
ficou lá estudando para o sistema de
ensino superior a dizer ou se eu tivesse
estudado na universidade pública que é
super concorrido ela desperdiçou
dinheiro público
alguém poderia estar naquela vaga ela
estudou no ensino superior privado como
sete em cada dez alunos matriculados no
brasil
ela perdeu dinheiro dela da família ou
de quem pagou aquela mensalidade né
imagina lacerta estudando 23 anos e aí
você fala nossa errei não era isso não
família assis pagar aqui tudo minha
mensalidade um empréstimo ou
financiamento mas eu errei
você quiser a chinês e quem escolhe
errado e fica errado o errado dá medo de
errar então vou ficar me ferrar também
não vou ficar vou ficar aqui no curso tá
acabando meu pai pressiona já paguei
quase informando vai que depois mudou de
idéia
essa pessoa vai se ferrar mais ainda
porque ela tem na área errada e ela sabe
disso
imagina só você trabalhar numa área que
você não gosta
e você sabe que você não gosta e você
sabe que você queria ser outra coisa
essa pessoa vai ser produtiva não porque
ela vai ser infeliz pensando num retrato
macro a gente com esse sistema de ensino
superior ea gente está formando
mão-de-obra altamente qualificada que
são as pessoas com ensino superior
o risco de não serem tão produtivas
porque o que ela quer para a vida dela o
que ela faz
são incompatíveis
quem escolheu certo agora a pessoa
respira aliviada não mesmo que você tem
que escolheu certo quem escolheu certo
se ferra
por que escolher uma carreira específica
no brasil a gente tem que escolher uma
carreira específica à especificidade
atenta contra a interdisciplinariedade
que a bola da vez ensino superior
enquanto em grande universitário
universidades do mundo a argentina entra
na universidade
genericamente uma grande área vai
desenvolver habilidades e vai aprendendo
a falar em público a negociar a escrever
e aí eu vou tendo disciplinas técnicas
no brasil a gente forma para uma de uma
carreira específica com conhecimento
técnico para uma carreira que pode nem
existir no futuro
mas calma que tem solução
a primeira coisa hoje em dia
revelando a idade novamente
diferentemente de quando eu entrei na
universidade há quase 20 anos
a gente tem informação hoje eu consigo
acessar o ranking universitário folha eu
consigo ver rankings internacionais que
comparam universidades do brasil com
universidades estrangeiras para ter uma
noção de como aquela instituição eu
consigo ver a avaliação do mec
eu consigo entrar na página do curso que
eu quero fazer e ver quais são as
disciplinas
eu consigo mandar um email para os
professores que têm lá o nome dos
professores e meio eu consigo entrar na
página do facebook de um curso e b que
os alunos estão falando é melhor na
entrada
eu consigo falar com especialistas em
educação bom eu tenho uma coluna online
a folha de são paulo chamado the cw
convido vocês lerem
eu recebo constantemente meio de pessoas
que precisam decidir a carreira
aliás recentemente recebi um e mail de
uma pessoa que quer fazer medicina
porque gosta de grey's anatomy e aí o
campeonato naquela série médica é que
retrata a realidade de um hospital
privado eu também adoro grey's anatomy
se alguém tiver spoiler na próxima
temporada tudo sentada ali me procura
hoje a gente tem informação tem outra
coisa a gente pode hackear o sistema bom
time que tem informação consigo escolher
uma carreira de uma maneira mais
esclarecida mas eu tenho que escolher
uma carreira específica
a gente pode tentar fazer com que essa
carreira específica seja mais
interdisciplinar
hoje em dia eu posso fazer cursos online
em plataformas brasileiras e
estrangeiras fora da minha área eu posso
escolher disciplinas optativas fora da
minha área eu posso tentar fazer
disciplinas extras
a maioria das universidades permite isso
fora da minha área
ninguém me falou isso eu não sabia disso
mas quando eu fiz universidade eu fiz
disciplina
não estudei jornalismo que disciplina a
psicologia da física à biologia nas
relações internacionais
o desenho industrial e nas engenharias
era nerd eu ficava pensando disciplina e
o que eu aprendi nas engenharias olha só
na estatística que estudantes de
engenharias me permitiu muitos anos
depois não tantos anos depois alguns
anos foi fazer um ranking ele vai estar
folha carreira e interdisciplinar mas
falta que um elemento chave
para fechar essa equação
e esse elemento chave é você imagina só
se cada um de nós se a gente ajudar se
ao então um aluno se a gente pegasse um
aluno que alguém que tá prestando ensino
superior que querem entrar no entanto a
singular que entrar no ensino superior
a gente sentar se com esse aluno pode
ser seu filho pode ser seu pai pode ser
um desconhecido pode ser um filho do
manobrista do comércio que você passa
todo dia a gente sentar se com ele e
compartilhar essas informações que a
gente tem as fontes de informação se a
gente ouve se sugerir se a gente fala
fala fala que fulano beltrano já que
está com dúvida entre essas duas
carreiras vamos naquele trabalho vamos
naquela universidade
a gente orientasse uma pessoa se a gente
orientar essa pessoa para que ela
consiga na carreira específica ter uma
carreira interdisciplinar construir uma
carreira interdisciplinar
se cada pessoa que lhes pede que está
assistindo orienta uma pessoa já são
centenas de pessoas excesso a ideia se
espalhar
a gente pode chegar a milhares de
pessoas que vão tomar uma decisão de
maneira mais informada e diminui a
margem de erro a gente não consegue nem
se ted mudar a forma de ingresso no
ensino superior do país
mas a gente pode fazer com que os está a
rigidez do sistema influencie - a tomada
de decisão das pessoas
obrigada
[Música]
[Aplausos]